all right hello welcome the last day the
morning after the party I'm glad you are
all here so this is an interesting talk
I often do talks where I'll say like
here's all the new features here's a
list of all the different things who
here was at my talk yesterday where I
kind of showed off about so that was
kind of a here's all the stuff that's in
the box and what I kind of wanted to do
for this is take a look at here are some
things I would do when I'm building a
website the the team has to be when they
build these templates they're very
careful what they ship they want to give
you just enough so that you that you can
get started that that you're not kind of
left out there writing a ton of code on
your own but they don't want to give you
too much code they don't want to give
you a bunch of code that's going to
annoying you that you'll have to delete
also they any code that they ship they
have to maintain later right and so
there's kind of this balance of trying
to get just enough in the box and then
also give you the freedom to kind of go
and explore after that so I wanted to
take a look at what I would add if I was
adding some stuff so this is my one
slide I've got a gist and if you just if
you look on gist and look for John
Galloway it's my most recent my most
recent gist and I've got just a ton of
links and stuff and it's kind of a long
checklist and what I'm hoping from this
is that we can that some of these things
you'll learn and you'll say hey that's a
good idea
I'm hoping a decent amount of others
you'll look at you'll say that's a
terrible idea
which means it's good it's not in the
box and I would also love to hear your
ideas this is small enough group if
you've got ideas throw a hand out there
there's somebody with a mic or you can
just let me know and I'll repeat it and
and we'll take a look maybe we'll add in
something and I learn something to sound
good from you're just just for reference
from me who here is like way up to date
on everything with asp.net they've got a
SP neck core to to preview
to install they all that kind of stuff
okay there's there's a few okay cool who
here has like basically no knowledge
like they'd be scared if they were told
they needed to ride in is peanut core
app somebody there's a few people I hope
good okay so we've got a balance keep
that in mind if you're like super
advanced and you're like what are you
talking about waste my time there's some
people here that are new to this and
then also slow me down if you've got if
I'm rushing through a bit so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to start just kind
of hey shown up to work Monday morning
I've got a new project to build its a
mini site it is a site with a I'm kind
of modeling this after what we did for
what we do for our workshops in general
so there's this is peanut Cora app
workshop and I originally was just
planning on doing file new project web
app and I realized there's a little bit
more that I wanted to kind of start
thinking about that that was a little
too simplistic so this is peanut core
web app what we do is we build a a
front-end which is just a web app we
build like some some DT O's some some
just kind of standard stuff in a in a
dotnet standard library and then we
build a a back-end that has api's and
then as part of this like this past week
I at the workshop I also attacked on a
blazer front-end and stuff so part of
the reason I did this was to start
thinking about what do we do with
calling like configuring API calls and
multi-tier stuff another thing is it's
very easy to start building out an
application and then your folder
structure is all wrong because you only
have one project in it
so who here builds solutions that always
have more than one project in it that's
right so I wanted to be a little bit
more real-world who here like regularly
has projects with like or solutions with
over 50 projects in them okay that
always like freaks me out because I like
to keep it small and have like NuGet
packages for sharing and stuff but I
know real world people are you know
doing bigger things so cool so
as a just kind of general reference this
thing here I'll add a link to that to
that just so it'll show up um but this
is this a is peanut core app workshop
and was anyone here at the workshop this
week okay
it's it's it's all online and this is
something where if you want to kind of
learn asp net core in more detail this
has it's all written out as like a
walkthrough it's a tutorial and you can
go through and you know it'll say and
now create this class and now you're
going to configure it you know and and
so you're going through and building an
entire application alright so let's do
this I am going to I've got a few that
I'm going to refer to but I'm actually
going to just you file me and there's a
few different ways to structure a
solution when you're building something
out there there's two different
questions that I think of right away one
is do I want to if I'm going to be
putting it up on github or in source
control do I create it in the repo first
and then you know clone an empty repo
and then you know build my thing and
push to that or do I start building
locally and then I go out and create the
repo show of hands which do you prefer
do you prefer to build locally for a
while and then create a repo and throw
it up there that's I'm guessing that's
kind of more likely I try to do that as
early as possible though it's way too
it's way too easy to code for a while
and then something happens my laptop
died this summer and I lost some work
and it reminded me that it's like always
be pushing code right so so there's a
few ways that you can go through and
configure a multi project solution one
way that we've got in here is
command-line you can go through and you
do dotnet dotnet ad and you you kind of
build it from command-line here's
another thing you can do is when you
create a project you can go in and
there's a thing in here other solution
types no where is it it's it's hiding
the way I made skip over it if I can't
find it it's uh there it is
blank solution anyone know about this
already this was this is actually not
that common of one so I'm gonna call
this Sydney
[Music]
cool alright so we'll create that blank
solution then I can go through and add
projects to this part of the reason I'm
doing this is just to be specific about
where I want my solution files I hate it
when I create a project and then I add
other projects in and then my solution
file is in nested in a project and all
that kind of stuff right so now I'm
going to add a few different things to
this and we'll be popping over regularly
to this checklist so we are at setup
solution so I'm gonna go I'm gonna do
that so I'm going to add in two other
projects in here so I'll do add the
project and of course I can do this all
command-line NetApp project etc so here
we'll go there we'll do you use peanut
core web app we'll just call this web
app and I am doing this I'm I want to do
this you with ASP net for two one it's
it in some ways kind of breaks my heart
because I like doing all the new and
shiny but I want to show you something
that's actually shipping code so I'm
gonna go with that for now so I'm gonna
go with this is not such a difficult
decision anymore
normally I'd have to go I'll do I want
authentication or not as I showed in my
talk yesterday you can scaffold and add
authentication in later so we'll keep it
lightweight and not a death on occasion
I'll do that and then I'm going to
create a few other projects and Adam in
here too we'll throw in a that DTO
project an API project and breaking with
tradition I'm actually going to even
throw in a test project so let's do add
project click on solution
all right I know this is exciting we'll
move on to the next fun stuff in a
second
now we'll do an API all right cool
will so we'll start with that there so
now we've got our kind of standard thing
now step two on this and and some of
this actually I've gotten through just
kind of running through this a few times
and and trial and error and saying oops
this this would bug me if I did this so
the next thing I actually want to do is
add in a global Jason so the reason for
that is if I go
I've got dotnet court - to preview - on
here and this is I think pretty
regularly you know this is something
where I'm experimenting I'm working with
multiple different versions and I
actually would like to manage my version
separately for this in this case I'm
going to be building with HP net for two
one and there are some things that break
if I don't do that
so how I'm going to do that is using SDK
dot node SDK list so this is a cool
project it's just a neat open-source
thing it's it's pretty quick install is
anyone using this net net SDK list this
is pretty handy for for managing
multiple versions so it's something that
I would I it's not yet a global 200 I
would expect it will be soon but it's
it's a super quick install and what's
neat with this is I can go then in this
application I can say dotnet SDK 2.1 dot
or or - so it just writes that out so
now let's take a look I end up opening
usually Visual Studio code and Visual
Studio which is a little goofy I realize
but sometimes some just seem kind of
more you know appropriate some so anyhow
yeah there it is I've got my global
Jason so that's cool
where are we at now so let's go to this
is an interesting one I asked around and
a lot of people recommended adding
directory build props who here adds that
- like everything they do okay not many
people cool so we'll check that out
so directory it up build up props is
kind of neat what you can do there is
you can add and like an override that's
going to be merged in to your to your
all your build files so here let's go
over here and I'll grab this one and
we'll drop it in this one is a very very
simple one but the idea hopefully is is
you know then if there's other stuff you
need to configure you can do it looks
like I'll need to drag and drop it
did you do so I am putting that I'll put
this in the route I end up navigating a
lot of folders pretty regularly so
there's a lot of tricks there's the the
window left arrow right arrow there's
you can always like if I'm in a folder I
can do CMD dot and that'll pop open a
command line in that window and then if
I am in command window and I want to
open up the directory I can do starch
dot and that'll do the reverse so that's
that's pretty handy so if I'm hopping
around and doing that that's how it's
happening all right it's cool so now
when I go in and I let's take a look at
what's in that directory don't build up
props so that one is just this I've just
stopped it into a few things so I've
done things like set my name and company
you can also do things like here I'm
opting in to the latest language version
so this takes advantage of c-sharp 7/3
features there's not a whole lot in here
there's some advanced tuple support and
stuff but this is kind of just a
standard place where I can manage things
if I did want to set like language
version or version all all my assemblies
in one place I can set the version
number and stuff there so cool
all right so we are trucking through we
have got we have done these first three
so now I'm actually going to go out and
push this to get hub alright let's have
a vote who votes that I create the repo
and then push it versus the other option
I guess is pushed from inside visuals
stupor um inside Visual Studio cool all
right there you go sir alright who would
like me to go to github create a repo
and push our command line alright we'll
do that so
so part of the reason that I like to put
repose on you know push stuff to a repo
quickly is so that I can start getting
ci going I'm not going to have time
probably to set that up today but I
usually do set up stuff with Azure you
know like the azure CI build from github
and just even if it's just so I can ping
someone else on my team and say hey
check out this site or whatever also if
there are going to be any problems with
deploying the site and running it live I
want to know early so that's something
where I can just start doing that way at
the beginning and and save some time
so here I've already I've got some code
I don't have it in a command line so I'm
get or I don't have it in get yet so
I'll do get an int cool so then we can
go to I just go through and and you know
do all this sort of stuff here so I'm
gonna do a git add dot and this is the
one thing I want to copy there so mmm
what happened there because I'm running
that's awesome not sure why it would be
running oh they have to kill my server
yeah good plan so now I have to get him
like you know I actually am gonna be
lame and I had this via here if anyone
walks out I'll understand so this is
kind of neat though that you can go
through and do this this all hopefully
so when I did this earlier today it
actually created that get ignoring stuff
for me which is kind of nice so I don't
have to mess with that syntax so I think
I can do this now cool all right so
there we go
now whoa
push it my rule of thumb is anything
over about 50 characters I'm in a copy
and paste cool all right I do like to
and I know there's a lot of different
workflows and some people are really
kind of dogmatic about which one I
actually like to hop between all of them
I like to go command-line I like to use
the visual studio tools and I like to
use vs code and I feel like there's a
lot of times where sometimes if I'm
doing like I've got a hundred files I
don't want to kind of go like wait and
I'll use I'll use just vs code for that
if I'm doing just a quick commit or
something I'll use I'll use command line
and then for kind of more like if I'm
dipping or stuff like that I'll use
Visual Studio so so cool there we are so
now we're we are open-source developers
so that's exciting my next step is going
to have me probably still staying in
here so good add a license so this is
actually I think a pretty important
thing to do and even if I'm doing it for
like a website that I'm putting up
some some people will say you know like
don't worry about a license don't don't
get all uptight about it but really if
you don't create a license you're not
letting people use your code people you
know if they're if they're looking at
open source code on the Internet
well if it doesn't have a license it's
not really open source right so there I
type in license and here it gives me the
option it notices that and says you know
what kind of license I'm gonna go with
good old MIT it makes me feel smart and
add that cool and now we merge your own
pull request so this is something where
you know again this is I could obviously
have created this file on my local
machine I like to use the the tools
there and actually have like a
pre-populated MIT license and stuff so
cool lookin for a merge and then we'll
wipe that branch and then we'll pull it
local
awesome okay so there we go let's kill
that let's go over here so we've added
license now here's something where I'm
gonna go a little bit rogue
I built an asp net core application
however in looking at some of the
features and stuff that RNA and asp net
cor 2:2
there's a lot of stuff that i can start
using now and so what i like to do with
that and and it's there's always
trade-offs but i like to kind of take a
balanced approach and start pulling in
some of that more advanced stuff early
so i'm going to for instance start using
analyzers and then i'll use some things
like health checks and stuff like that
and again that's that's partly because
i'm like shiny things and i want to use
the new features but it's also because i
know it's coming and especially for a
relatively small application like this
or whatever I've kind of thought through
I know they're shipping at the end of
the year and I want to be able to as
soon as it goes live hop on to to to so
it's easiest for me if I can start
taking advantage of some of those
features so what i've what i've done
here is there several analyzers that are
available and these are part of what's
in the you know what's in the new
release stuff so here if i go pop these
into a so I've got this one say the
reference this is when I ran through
this before this is the reference you'll
notice an interesting thing here and
this is going to come up later the way
that we reference asp net core in like
as a reference now it doesn't have a
version and that's because it's just
managed for you it's going to be
whatever the the asp net core version is
that corresponds with sdk and stuff that
can come back to bite you though because
it is a version less reference so
there's something you have to do there
as far as like setting up health checks
and stuff okay so i'm going to now go in
and throw in these analyzers i also i'm
curious glen is this a horrible idea or
now it didn't
like anything so I thought it was cool
but now so we have one vote yes one vote
now I'm on stage I have the mic I'm
doing it so here we're gonna we're gonna
pop this in and so these ones I feel a
little bit less worried about because
their analyzers so analyzers are
something that checks for best practices
in my code as I'm developing it's not
something that I'm gonna push it out on
to the server and it's gonna explode
probably I mean probably won't explode
right so so I'm doing it so this is
something where we're not gonna write
any real code where we'll get to the
point where it's going to say hey your
your app sucks you know and change your
code but it's it's I like to just put
them in there it makes me happy
cool so now we've got some code we have
not actually written any real code so we
can do dotnet build just make sure it's
all there from back in the old day you
used to have to first do dotnet restore
on everything before doing dotnet build
now it's it's implied that you're gonna
do that now one thing I also like to get
set up early on is is the whole kind of
dotnet watch workflow so if I go to here
I could type just dotnet run and then
it's going to run my app and then if I
if I kill it it they if I'm gonna make
changes to the code I'm gonna have to
keep stopping it and then you know
running it again and stuff so there's
another trick you can do where you can
use dotnet watch run and what that'll do
is it'll watch for changes in my code
and it'll like so my my backend c-sharp
code you know it'll rebuild that so it's
it's got a file watcher hooked up to the
build process so then I really like that
for kind of a quick process where I'm
going through I'm tweaking something it
may be some some front end or some back
end code and I can keep refreshing right
so that used to be something that took
some some set up because you had to
install a new get package directly in
each project that was using it but now
that's a global tool so any project
you're working on
that'll work with so there's there's
really nothing you have to set up there
okay another cool thing here is dotnet
outdated so this again is just something
as part of the workflow I like to
regularly check so oops outdated so this
is a global tool this is a community
tool and this is going to look at my
project and say are any of your nougat
packages out-of-date so that that's
pretty helpful so here I'm just doing it
in that one web app if I go here so for
the whole solution it's going to check
and it's gonna let me know now again
since I just created this it's not
really likely to have any kind of
problems but if I was building say like
a build dot bad or something like that I
would want to include this and I'd want
to be looking at this and seeing if I
have any outdated dependencies so this
is this is a global tool I've got
installed here's
now it's gonna tell me how to type it
yeah it's a dotnet tool so these are the
global tools I've got installed and I I
think they're fun to click they're free
you can go out and Nate McMaster has a
list of them so these are all these
global tools and so this is this is
something we're not going to do right
now but this is something where we may
even if we have like a build chain these
are things where we can starting
including into that and to like a build
dot bat right if you're interested in
writing these these are actually the
this one will be a little bit longer but
they're they're actually relatively
simple to do you can look at source code
for them out on nougat and and they're
they're relatively straightforward it's
just a console application right so cool
we have checked for that now we're gonna
actually start and again we're not we're
not like customizing the app this is
more the kind of setup stuff to make
sure we've got a good solid start so now
I want to go through and start
configuring functional tests functional
tests are something that that was just
made available in asp net core to one
and the idea with this there's there's
of course unit tests and unit tests you
point it at a function specific like
unit of code and you say run this code
with these input parameters and i expect
these output parameters so that can be
useful if you've got your code factored
out into things where you've got like a
very specific service and you're
checking you know if i if i submit this
thing do I have permission to do this or
if I you know am I am i running one
specific block of code and getting the
right thing out the problem with that
can be that a lot of time for web
applications they don't really that
they're not that useful right a lot of
the time what you really want to know is
if I hit this web page does it come up
or if I browse to this URL does it
redirect to this other URL so in the
past in order to do that you
had to do a decent amount of work you
had to either use something like
selenium or you had to do some sort of
like basically spinning up your app in
order to test it problem with that is
that it's heavy weight and your tests
take longer and you end up not writing
or using the tests and and so the idea
with this feature functional tests is to
make it easy for you to ping something
like a page or an MVC URL and say what
do I get back from that you know if I
hit this page does it redirect to this
other page so you you test more that
whole functional workflow but it's a
nice kind of balance between it's big
enough to be useful but it's small
enough that it actually is all running
in memory it's not spinning up the
entire website so it's kind of it's a
more kind of a low-key in the middle
sort of thing so for this I've actually
gone through and I've I've had to this
is wrong just this is both it is cool
and it also is kind of a it doesn't it
doesn't perfectly work right now and so
there's some problems with it the
problem is that I mentioned before that
we're using this version 'less asp net
core web app thing so if we go in here
we take a look at our CS proj and this
is just SP net core not dot app so as of
right now if you create a test project
and you point it at this project it says
I don't know how to load that assembly
so this is something that will be fixed
into two but as for right now if you
just create a new X unit project and try
and do functional tests you actually
have to go and tweak this does anyone
run into this yet nobody here okay well
maybe I if if maybe I saved you a half
hour or something because it's kind of a
pain so I'm going to go in and create a
test project
all right so we are creating an X unit
test project and we'll call this web app
tests all right so that is just a
standard X unit test project now into
this we're going to add a reference to
our web app add reference there we go
okay cool so now at this point we
actually have to go in and edit our CS
proj in order to define the version for
that so in thing where we go so here so
here's my my um reference and I actually
have to go in and add a specific
reference to asp net core dot app with
this so throw that in part part of the
reason i'm spending some time mentioning
this you get crazy errors like it
doesn't it's it's not something like oh
it kind of almost worked it's like you
get bizarre errors that don't make any
sense so now we're going to add a new
get package so that we can do that so
that we can do the functional testing
and so that is
Microsoft is peanut core MVC testing is
anyone using these I'm working well for
you cool alright hopefully hopefully
what I want to do like is just make you
aware of a bunch of things again you'll
have other things you're like I can't
believe you didn't do that thing and
setup spriting or whatever but some of
this stuff I think is good to do from
the beginning and this is something
where you know starting in a project I
think this is worthwhile to get it set
up right so cool alright so there we
have that let me go over and check into
this so there we have our references and
now I'm going to go in and I'm gonna set
up a simple health check so this is this
is going to ping a few of our like file
new project pages and it's just going to
verify that it gets gets a response it
gets a 200 header so cool
alright we'll rename this to functional
tests
and of course like over time I'd
probably break this down more and stuff
wow I just selected all in the solution
Explorer that's scary cool alright it's
all have probably a few things to
resolve maybe not these two chairs
will well note that i haven't committed
for a while which is kind of a no-no so
i really need to do that in a second
so I should be able to I'll show you the
tests in a second but hopefully I want
to verify that they actually run and
they all ran just kidding they did not
run okay so and I may need to screw with
my CS prod somewhere
so we do have you know what my web app
was not created using the right template
is that right it's not a pages
application it's a web api
well my tests actually did something
very valuable for me I did that all
completely on purpose there to show you
the value yeah so let's go ahead and
delete that one wow that's amazing
fortunately I hadn't customized it much
so cool you saw it here today well your
functional tests are the best thing okay
there we go see I thought by calling it
a web app that would just by convention
I'm gonna have to go and delete it out
or something
[Music]
cool
everybody watch close make sure I do the
right thing this time okay yeah we
should be good cool
Wow I'm sold on this testing thing then
we'll make sure that our tests are on
then we'll commit and then we'll start
hopping around well I think we'll look
at health checks next after that oh I
may have to reset the reference let me
verify I've got my tests add in a
reference here
build everything cool wow I didn't have
it in the right folder and it's like
stuck red now which is kind of crazy
everything I do is wrong from here on
out Wow alright so five failed so we may
screw with this for a bit more and then
we may move on because I don't want to
debug tests too much here let's make
sure that the website actually runs
first
all right so we have a functioning
website so if that doesn't work I'm a
hop over to this one that's that's
actually working more it may have to do
with this es proj and I may not have
copied all the stuff over set the
version in the in the web oh did I not
set it to - okay let's see so there's a
few places I could do that one is I
could go in here that is - one is that
is that we're talking about I think
that's it all right let's look - 2 - 1
line 8 so I don't think I need to set it
there
I think that from what I remember I'm
pretty sure that I needed to set it in
here but let's try it I'm willing to go
for that so and I can see what I had for
my previous one yeah so in the previous
one I actually did end up setting it in
the in here this is the X unit test so
we'll take one more look at that let me
look at this one so here we have kind of
my farther along solution let's come
here so yeah that just has dot app and
so in the web app itself runs let's take
a look at the CS proj in here so there I
have two one one one okay
I'm gonna be a goof and just copy all of
those over
yeah all right build it all again
there's not a huge amount of code more
in the next one so we'll hop hop over to
that in a second oh and we should I'm
looking for a semicolon or whatever it
is so
if I was a fast typer I would just
switch over to my working solution run
the tests and you'd be like hey look
actually it all did work
did anyone spot what changed no all
right this is one of those things where
like so people make fun of engineers to
where they're like how dumb is it to
just run the same code over and over and
expect it to like do something different
but I think we just all saw right I mean
what's that so I don't think maybe I
mean it's possible
let's look here's the the unit test
project so the actual application still
is and there's another thing in there
where you can go and say which which
exact you know dotnet version am i
running on I'm not sure but I will tell
you this I got to close this console
window because the red is just killing
me so next we're gonna look at health
checks and so here's here's kind of our
general plan just so you kind of know
where we're going we're going to set up
health checks I'm going to show you
quickly how to how to set up mini
profiler and may skip over that then
I've got some front end set up stuff and
then I've got I'll just kind of walk
through and point out some other kind of
cool stuff so I need to save a good I
don't know five ish minutes at the end
to point out some other stuff part of
part of where this all comes from is
does anyone here watch this SP net
community stand up so we do this every
Tuesday it alternates between us time
between 10 a.m. and 3:45 p.m. so usually
every other week works for you and my
mental bringing time math doesn't work
but one of these times should work for
you and here's this 8:45 a.m. that
sounds good to me so we've done 150
shows so we just finished four years of
these we have all these kind of things
where we
two people on the the the dev team weed
and and so as part of this I always show
off community links at the beginning and
so I've got this huge huge list of
here's some neat things that people in
the community are doing here's some
recommendations here's some different
ideas and so that's that's part of
what's influenced this cool let's do
health checks so health checks is a
feature that I believe was in like it's
available to run on to one but it's
really going to be kind of shipping as a
full full fledged feature into two so I
can go in and add that using so it's
Microsoft asp net core diagnostics
health checks so let's add that in so
the idea with first I should commit some
stuff to you not in that cursed window
okay
and I realize I skipped over probably
the most important thing there which is
what those functional tests actually did
so let me show you that real quick what
this is doing is there's some startup
stuff where it knows how to actually
spin up your application then here it's
an X unit test so you can all these
different in line data you can you can
point a bunch of stuff at it you say run
this test over and over plugging all
this different stuff into this URL
parameter so first go to the home page
then go to index about privacy contact
etc and then for each of those it's
going to go in and it's just going to
ensure it's got a success status code
and that it's got a content header with
the so it's getting back a content
header so actually we can go in let's
delete one just for fun so if I delete
the contact page cool and then now let's
do so we should see now that that's one
test fails if that one page doesn't come
back
cool alright so does not indicate
success we got a 404 on that page so now
I have two choices one is I could fix
that page or two is I could decide I
don't want that page and then I can get
rid of that and now my test should work
so again this is kind of a higher level
chunkier test that's gonna say for my
entire page do these you know entire
site did the pages come up alright so
this is a little bit different from a
health check so what a health check does
is it is something where I can point
something at my website and say if you
know if these different things happen
return yes my site is healthy so an
example of where this would be come in
handy is you could say if my site can
reach the database its healthy if my
site you know or conversely if my site
can't reach the database its unhealthy
or if my site is missing the following
configuration variables its unhealthy
that kind of stuff so it's something
where you can go through and make a list
of you know in code sort of stuff what
is my site need to have to be considered
healthy what's nice with that is these
health checks are pretty standard for
something like traffic manager and Azure
so you can have multiple instances of
your site running if one can't reach the
database it goes offline rather like
then the health checks immediately fail
and so then as your sends everybody to
the working instance of the site so
there's a lot of other stuff you can do
with this you can write your own kind of
custom code for it but some like I
mentioned some of those kind of obvious
things are is the site even functional
and then if it is functional can it does
it have like the configuration values
and that kind of stuff and again this is
something where it's it's this is at
runtime versus your unit tests are going
to be at you know build time right as
I'm writing my code I'm running my unit
tests and then as I as my site's up live
in production I'm able to ping the unit
tests or the health checks and say you
is my site actually running cool I'm
sure that's gonna go away cuz that's
what's that's how things are working
today okay so now I'm going to go in
this is actually really easy to
configure a health check so I can go in
and I can do at the very basic level I
can say services I add health checks and
then down here I can say app use health
checks and then I can say return health
so what this is going to do is when I
run my site let's do it
so when I read my site and I browse to
slash health I should get either healthy
or unhealthy so the default one that
comes in the box just says it's gonna
say healthy right and then there's other
so this this would not return anything
or whatever if the sites offline we ping
this and it's not gonna work but then
there's other things we can go in where
you can go in and so here's some of
these samples where they go in and they
say here's one for instance where I ping
a database and there's my database
connection work and it's going to do
things like ensure do I even have the
right configuration for that and stuff
so here that it actually is running a
database command and I think it just
does a select one or something it's a
very kind of lightweight sort of thing
and then there's others you know is
here's here's so there's sequel or that
was the database connection here's a
sequel connection so there's all kinds
of different ones you can do where you
can say like this is how I've defined my
application to be healthy right so now
just to kind of I do want to test around
that health check make sure my health
check is actually working so we'll just
quickly pop one of those in there too so
we're doing a unit test verifying my
health check so this one is just a fact
because we don't need multiple different
ones going in so I'll go in here and
we'll add one new method at the end so
this says if I ping health I'm expecting
the result to be healthy so
so once this is done we're gonna look at
some front-end stuff real quick so one
of the front end things that that I like
to hook up is the current templates are
running on bootstrap 3 and the kind of
the 3 point and it's like three point
three point seven I think the new
version is dotnet or is a bootstrap for
bootstrap four has some some good stuff
flex box and a lot of other kind of more
updated stuff and so in order to do that
what I would want to use is Lib man and
this is maybe a contentious thing but
there's a few different ways that you
can handle your front-end dependencies
so if you are writing something like a
mostly like a very front-end heavy
application if you're using a lot of NPM
packages if you're doing you know like
whole angular thing and you need to
transpile and you need web pack and all
that by all means you should be using
that stuff like I'm not you know telling
you you shouldn't if you are starting
from scratch and you know you are going
to be building a like a reactor or a
angular application I'd recommend one of
these templates because it wires it in
with a is peanut core pretty well so
this uses JavaScript services and it's
all tested and all that so if you're
building a you know an application
that's using react or angular or
whatever definitely I would you
recommend using that however in this
case we're just using I just want to
throw a bootstrap in there I'm not going
to dev on bootstrap I'm not you know
doing any kind of I don't have less or
sass or I don't have any of that other
stuff so from that point of view I can
go in and I can do manage client-side
libraries so this manage client slide
libraries lets me go in and add other I
can point other libraries at it so what
this does is it actually gets it will
get those libraries off of it will get
those libraries off of CDN so here if I
went in and do this from here let's say
I wanted to add in
client-side library so this will say it
can go and get it from like CD nsj or
unpackage or from the file system and I
can point it at something so let's say
for instance I did want jQuery then I
can go in I'll say boom there's jQuery
and then I can also go in and pick
specific files that I want and it'll pop
those into into the root so I think it's
it's waiting a second do to Australia's
tremendously fast internet but don't
don't have that one yet what I do want
to show you is how I've set this up I've
set this up in another website that we
just shipped recently and so this is the
dotnet Foundation website so this
website has been a fun one this is one
that I kind of that I it is a production
website it's something that I mostly run
and it's a good thing to kind of keep me
honest and and make sure that the stuff
I'm telling you to do actually it does
work for me in production too so this is
a site where we did update it so the the
site looks it's asp net cor 2:2
it's just last week we shipped this so
this is a bootstrap 4 theme and it's got
you know it's taking advantage all the
kind of bootstrap you stuff so the way
that we did that here if I go in and
we'll do manage play inside libraries
and you'll see here that's how I kind of
and in order to get this set up I
actually kind of went in and did some
some manual work there to do that so
that is kind of how I went in and and
set that up if you are interested in
updating an existing site you can get
this this code this is that site is
actually out on github
so you can take a look at the the source
code for it so is dotnet foundation
website and so the code that I set up
for this one is I set it up in live man
and then to is going in and configuring
all this stuff so this is an important
thing to kind of spend some time on it's
definitely more than like the five
minutes I have left here but the idea is
that you're setting up CDN and local
links for these things so when you're
running locally you you may want to be
using local copies of the files when
you're in production you want to use the
CDN versions but if if a fallback is
available you want to use it so for
instance in this case I'm using here's
bootstrap coming from the CDN and then
this asp net fallback stuff is pretty
cool what it does is it says test for
this class so look for this class check
for the property position and if make
sure that it's absolute so it actually
loads set CSS this is on the client it's
going to basically verify for the SR
reader class is position equal to
absolute if it is fine you've loaded off
the CDN if not then it gets it off of
your local file system or off of your
server right so the idea is you get the
benefit of CDN but you get the fallback
if the CDN is offline so that's that's
kind of how I set that up so that is
this is my overly optimistic like in an
hour I was like wow we could do so much
stuff and it is time consuming right but
here's some other things that I do want
to kind of point out are neat and
worthwhile one is mini profiler so many
profiler is anyone using mini profiler
any profiler cool so the idea is that
you can actually profile and see the
performance impact of things on your
website and it's a
it is a pretty lightweight installed
that they actually it's built by the
people at Stack Overflow and Stack
Exchange and it's been designed so that
they actually say you can run it in
production it shouldn't have a
noticeable impact in performance so so
there's that for front-end stuff Mads
Christiansen builds a ton of neat kind
of front-end things and so a few that I
think are worthwhile one is this bundler
minna fire so this is if you have a good
amount of like front-end code CSS
JavaScript it can actually bundle and
minify it for you so this is not a full
like web pack replacement or anything
like that it doesn't do things like
compiling less and sass but it is a
pretty good just kind of bundler minify
her thing another kind of more advanced
option is if you use this web optimizer
and what web optimizer does is is
actually middleware and it's a little
bit more fidgety to set up but you can
you can build out things like bundles
and stuff so this is something I'm
keeping an eye on it hasn't been quite
as updated recently is anyone using this
right now web optimizer so Mads builds a
ton of awesome stuff he's he's on the
visual studio extension team now but he
builds a ton of stuff but I'm always
kind of checking like what is this the
newest newest because it comes at you
fast I'm including it in this just
several links on integration testing if
you want to go deeper Scott Hanselman
wrote some posts on it
explaining also health checks there's
there's links there one thing that you
know the good next step into the API
section is configuring actual like
policies so that's something where you
can say if if it fails you know if I
call do I call back if I if I call and
it fails twice do I wait a bit before I
call back a third time that kind of
thing
if you are interested in building a
front-end with bootstrap I've got some
links in there
and then I guess one other last one I'd
kind of like to leave with is this web
developer checklist so this again this
is from Mads Christiansen and this is
good just any website on the Internet
should consider this stuff so there's
all sorts of things like you know best
practices including things like page
score even stuff like including humans
text and stuff on your site so the some
of these things where it's just kind of
hey did you check this thing is it
localized is it you know it's the color
contrast good that kind of thing
so that's that's an hour it's a it's
like I said I had this I also had a
OneNote that was like you know huge and
like trying to think of what you can
actually get through in an hour is
interesting so I hopefully this at least
kind of made you think of what are some
things I want to do every project when I
get started so I think we're out of time
for questions but I'm happy to talk to
anyone up front thank you